Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Da ist wieder so einiges passiert. Bisschen was an der Tabellenspitze. Heute geht es aber eher um das untere Gefilde der Tabelle. Erklär ich euch gleich hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 261. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt zum Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen uns mal wieder mit der 2. Bundesliga der Männer auseinandersetzen. Denn die hört ja irgendwie nicht auf Geschichten zu produzieren und die wollen wir hier abbilden. Mein Name ist Max Jakob-Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und ich begrüße heute bei mir eine tolle Runde. Ich freue mich sehr, dass sie alle hier sind. Zum einen haben wir hier eigentlich ein Kollegen-Duell, ne, eine Kollegen-Kooperation. Zum einen ist Fadi Keblawi da von den Nürnberger Nachrichten. Der Ed Gopeng hörst auf Twitter und man kann ihn auch hören im KDEP Podcast. Hallo Fadi, schön, dass du wieder hier bist. Guten Tag, hallo, ich freue mich. Ich freue mich ebenso. Michael Fischer ist nämlich auch hier, auch von den Nürnberger Nachrichten und vom 4. Flachpass, dementsprechend auch als Flachpass-Unterstrich, auf Twitter zu finden. Siehst du, wie leicht das jetzt mir von der Lippe geht? Michi, du hast alles richtig gemacht. Danke, dass du dich umbenannt hast und schön, dass du hier bist. Ja, sehr gut. Das ist schön, dass ihr nicht nur hier mit dabei seid, sondern zum Teil auch aktive Hörer seid. Und ich glaube, das können wir auch über Louis Loeser sagen. Er ist unter anderem Fanradio- und Blindenreporter beim SV Sandhausen, dementsprechend auch der Experte zum SVS. Er ist der Ad-Regionalkapital auf Twitter. Hallo Louis, schön, dass du mal wieder hier bist.
Aber das heißt quasi, wenn du jetzt dann Neuzugänge nennst, die jetzt eine gute Phase haben und mit dazu beigetragen haben, also das habe ich ja noch gar nicht gesagt, aus den letzten drei Spielen 7 Punkte geholt, Sandhausen. Zweimal gewonnen, einmal unentschieden. Das ist ja das, was überhaupt Sandhausen noch da unten mit drin hält. Ansonsten die anderen, wir haben ja unter anderem über Rostock gesprochen, die wären jetzt schon viel, viel weiter weg. Also wenn das Neuzugänge sind und gleichzeitig du mir sagst, der jetzige Trainer ist der Scouting-Chef, dann wirkt das ja so, als ob Kleppinger vor allem erstmal die vorhandenen Spieler offenbar ein bisschen besser einsetzt. Kann das sein?
Also ich glaube, er hat auf jeden Fall schon mal einen absoluten Plan, was er mit der Mannschaft anstellen will. Und das sind auch nicht nur zwingend Neuzugänge, sondern so jemand wie Arne Sicker, der schon in der Winterpause gehen sollte eigentlich. Und der aber auch schon in der ersten Amtszeit unter Kleppinger einer der war, die eher gesetzt waren, weil er einfach weiß, was er an ihm hat. Also Arne Sicker ist jetzt kein absolut begnadeter Techniker, aber der macht dahinten halt seinen Job. Und der ist auch sehr flexibel einsetzbar. Der ist ja eigentlich Linksverteidiger, spielt jetzt diesen linken Part in der Dreierkette und macht das einfach sehr, sehr gut, sehr stabil. Und ja, da sieht man halt bei Kleppinger die viel zitierte Erfahrung und einfach, dass er diesen Verein halt in- und auswendig kennt. Und ja, ich glaube, das ist schon ein sehr großer Faktor. Und der andere ist, dass er eben auch einfach, ich glaube, da schon nochmal ein bisschen eine neue, neues Selbstbewusstsein entfacht hat. Was natürlich auch mit den Punkten kommt, aber auch gegen Magdeburg war das von Beginn an ein ganz anderer Auftritt. Man war viel enger dran in den ganzen Zweikämpfen. Man ist jeden Fall hinterhergejagt. Auch das Gegenpressing war viel besser. Also da hat er auch schon noch einiges bewirkt.
Gut, also das ist die Trainerposition. Prognose, da bist du zu erfahren, gibst du nicht ab, ob das für Sandhausen klappt. Dann haben wir jetzt aber noch ein letztes Thema, denn während wir hier aufgezeichnet haben, hat der SVS bekannt gegeben, dass man einen neuen Sportdirektor hat, aber noch nicht verraten will, wer es ist, weil man The Mask Sportdirektor anscheinend jetzt spielen möchte, mit der Öffentlichkeit.
Ja, der sollte eigentlich ja schon vor zwei Wochen da sein. Also man hatte ja quasi wenige, ich glaube zwei Tage nach der Entlassung von Thomas Ural, war dann auch Mikael Kabacza nach fast vier Jahren als sportlicher Leiter weg. Und man hatte dann angekündigt, in den nächsten acht Tagen soll der neue Sportdirektor kommen. Jetzt hat es halt nochmal zwei Wochen länger gedauert, aber immerhin ist er jetzt da. Man will ihn unter anderem nicht kommunizieren, weil er offenbar noch bei einem anderen Klub vertraglich gebunden ist. Genau, was natürlich die Planung auch ein bisschen erschwert. Man hatte eigentlich gesagt, man möchte möglichst frühzeitig eben diese Personalien geklärt haben, damit man eben auch rechtzeitig mit der Planung für die kommende Saison beginnen kann. Sandhausen hat jetzt auch kein monströses Personal. Also man hat den Präsidenten Jürgen Machmeier und man hat den Geschäftsführer Volker Piekser. Und dann gäb es einen Scouting-Chef, der gerade noch nebenberuflich Trainer ist. Und ja, also viel mehr wäre da gar nicht mehr so da. Also man hat natürlich einen Team-Manager mit Klingmann und auch Tim Kister, der gerade noch keine, ich weiß nicht, ob er eine offizielle Funktion im Verein hat. Ich glaube, er hospitiert gerade viel. Der macht gerade auch so eine Sport-Manager-Ausbildung. Aber es braucht halt jetzt irgendeinen Kaderplaner, der sowohl für eine mögliche dritte Liga einen Plan hat, als auch für die zweite Liga. Ich hoffe da mal, dass man den neuen Mann, den man jetzt noch nicht kommunizieren möchte, möglichst auch frühzeitig einbinden kann. Offiziell ist er ab 1. Juli da. Das ist halt, ich glaube, vier Wochen vor Saisonbeginn. Da sollte vorher schon einiges geschehen. Gerade wenn es in die dritte Liga gehen sollte, da hat man drei Verträge, die in der Liga gültig sind. Wurde von Volker Piegser verraten. Da würde also einiges anfallen. Wäre natürlich optimal, wenn man da dann sich gar nicht mehr mit beschäftigen muss. Aber es wäre natürlich naiv, wenn man nicht auch für die dritte Liga mitplanen würde. Ich glaube schon, dass es konsequent wäre, Kabacca zu entlassen. Er hat auch schon sehr viel Kritik abbekommen, vor allem aus Fan-Kreisen. Ich weiß doch, hinter uns sitzen immer so ein paar Mecker-Opis bei uns auf der Medientribüne. Die rufen gefühlt seit zwei Jahren Kabacca raus.
Da muss man einfach Alex Zorninger kommen und den zeigen. Kannst du dir mal vorbeischicken, dass er für Ruhe sorgt?
Die offizielle Kritik von Machmeier war auf jeden Fall, dass man so ein bisschen seine DNA verloren habe. Man hat zu viele große Namen eingekauft. Ich meine, viele haben auch funktioniert. Diegmeier ist nicht nur image-technisch, sondern auch leistungsmäßig. Außer, dass er zuletzt sehr viel verletzt war. Aber davor war es ja schon stark.
Der ist beim SVS zum Meme geworden.
Ich durfte alle seine beiden Zweitligatore, die ersten beiden live miterleben und das erste sogar selbst reportieren.
Das wird mal Trivia zu deiner Person. Wenn du mal ein ganz alter Sportjournalist bist und man dann quasi einen Fußball-Quiz rund spricht, was kennzeichnet den frühen Löser? Dann ist das die Antwort.
Einmal das und dass ich vor allen Dingen bei diesem Tor erst gar nicht gerafft habe, dass es Dennis Diekmeier war, weil es mich so verwehrt hat. Aber ich hatte noch den Pakt parat, dass es sein erstes Profitor war. Das muss man dann aber auch wissen als Reporter. Also einmal die Geschichte, dass man eben viel nach Namen eingekauft hat. Also wenn man da jemanden voranstellen will, dann zum Beispiel Diego Contendo, der halt null Komma gar nicht funktioniert hat. Und dann die andere Sache, dass einfach die Mannschaft wenig harmoniert hat. Ich meine, einerseits war es auch ein Kunststück von Carpaccia, dass er gefühlt jedes Jahr einmal den halben Kader umgeschmissen hat. Und es hat trotzdem irgendwie funktioniert. Ich glaube, letztes Jahr 24 Neuzugänge, 24 Abgänge.
Und das ja immer für wenig Geld.
Also so ziemlich alle immer ablösefrei. Dieses Jahr waren es nur 13 Neuzugänge, 14 Abgänge. Nur in Anführungszeichen. Also das größte Problem hatte ich ja vorhin schon angesprochen, dass es keinen Nachfolger für Testroth gefunden wurde, der dem Ruf des Geldes nach Ingolstadt gefolgt ist. Aber ja, insgesamt hat man einfach nichts Gefühl gehabt, dass der Kader super ausgewogen ist. Vielleicht hatte dann am Ende Kleppinger auch mehr Idee, was er damit anfangen soll als die anderen Trainer. Man weiß es nicht. Und andererseits kann man natürlich auch, ich glaube, was ihm am Ende das Genick gebrochen hat, war wirklich Thomas Oral, die Verpflichtung, der ja wie gesagt sein Mann war. Sie kannten sich schon, ich glaube, sogar zusammengespielt beim FSV Frankfurt, wo dann Kabacca später auch Teammanager war. Und der hat ja überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Und es war jetzt auch nicht das erste Mal, dass ein Trainer von ihm nicht super geklappt hat. Michael Schiele, wenn ich da zurückdenke. Im Braunschweig scheint es ja ganz okay zu laufen. Hat sie ja auch zurück in die 2. Liga geführt. In Sandhausen hat es überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Auch mit, ich glaube, allein mit seiner Art. Er hat einfach nicht geschafft, irgendwie in dieser Mannschaft Autorität auszustrahlen und irgendwie die Mannschaft hinter seiner Mission zu vereinen. Ich glaube, taktisch ist das ein überragender Trainer, aber er hat einfach null nach Sandhausen gepasst. Und gerade ihn dann als Nachfolger für Koshina zu holen, der in Sandhausen wirklich ein hohes Ansehen hatte und eigentlich ja schon einen einstelligen Tabellenplatz als Ziel ausgegeben hatte damals, war dann insgesamt…
Der letzte Tropfen der Berühmte. Also wir sehen, es ist viel passiert beim SVS, so wie ja auch beim Club und beim Kleeblatt. Also ich kann mir ganz entspannt angucken, wie jetzt die Saison läuft. Je nach Tabellensituation werdet ihr das ein bisschen angespannter tun. Aber es gibt ja auch noch in zwei Wochen die nächste Sendung zur 2. Liga und zumindest ist aktuell der Plan, es wird auch noch mal einen größeren Rückblick geben dann nach der Saison. Jetzt erstmal möchte ich mich aber bei euch dreien bedanken, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt für den Rasenfunk. Ich danke Fadi Keblawi, dem Ed Gopenghurst. Folgt ihm auf Twitter, es ist ein Spektakel. Danke dir, lieber Fadi. Dann danke ich Michi Fischer, dem Ed Flachpass unterstrich auf Twitter. Michi, es ist immer eine Freude dich hier zu haben. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Louis Loeser, der jetzt endlich auch mal über Sandhausen sprechen durfte. Sorry, Louis, das war mir nicht so klar. Du bist bei der TSG bei mir immer gesetzt, bei Sandhausen eigentlich auch. Mit wem habe ich denn ansonsten über Sandhausen gesprochen? Ich bin gerade ehrlich verwirrt. Aber schön, dass du hier warst.
Sehr gerne. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du jemals mit irgendwem dezidiert über Sandhausen bist.
Kann das wirklich sein?
Sonst empfehle ich immer den Kollegen von Carpe Diem. Der macht das auch super.
Ja, es gibt diese Schwerpunktkonzeption für den Zweitliga-Kurzpass. Das gibt es ja noch nicht so lange. Wahrscheinlich liegt es da drin.
Ich glaube auch. Und wer mich länger über Sandhausen reden will, der darf gerne am letzten Spieltag, wenn dann der HSV sich in die Relegation schießt, und Sandhausen vielleicht auch in die Relegation oder darüber hinaus zuhören, dann darf ich den hoffentlich nicht einen Hamburger Platzsturm reportieren. Ich finde, Nürnberg und Hannover sollten die einzigen Mannschaften bleiben, die in Sandhausen einmal den Platz umgemäht und das Ortsschild geklaut haben.
Hier, dann hört ihr den Hartwald Hörfunk, der ist dann eure richtige Adresse. In diesem Sinne, lieben Dank euch dreien und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Danke, dass ihr mit dabei wart. Und wie gesagt, nochmal der Hinweis, bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk finanziell. Es ist gut angelegtes Geld. Ich verspreche davon, mir keinen Pool zu kaufen. Das ist nicht in das Plan der ganzen Unterstützung. Also, es geht hier dann auch bald weiter. Wir machen natürlich als nächstes Männer-Bundesliga, Frauen-Bundesliga kommt dann auch hier im Kurzpass und es erscheint bald ein Tribüngespräch. Darauf könnt ihr gespannt sein. Macht's gut, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.